good morning Hank it's Tuesday so funny
story last night the Toyota nerdfighting
was in Houston we had a great time and
after we got done signing was like
midnight and we went to the hotel and
they told us that they had accidentally
sold our rooms and they were very sorry
oh pretty grandi because i really wanted
to go to bed then we had to go to a
different hotel and walking into the
other day like a total was kind of nice
and the guy behind the counter was like
we've reserved one of our best rooms for
you and I was like whatever I just want
to go oh my god or more Lorelai are
awesome I mean I think this place is
literally bigger than my house I'm not
even sure that I can sit in on the
chairs Sakichi telling you furnish their
house to find the main they are on there
together when it's time to procreate see
one or two young advice a female
underside and then slowly he becomes a
sperm producing Paris on
and if we could say here eternal healers
and till she dies and until that day he
literally never winter song
like without like never eating again we
just noticed this is an actual Picasso
print it's pretty unbelievable there's
like there's not even nailed down love
other things in the photo are not nailed
down you could just take it there's a
certificate of authenticity are you
serious yeah a home seated woman author
Pablo Picasso ha ha ha you're holding a
Picasso while eating Pringles first
you're retiring and becoming a
professional art thief no more toward a
nerd fighting for you this really ha ha
I never thought art thievery would be so
easy all of which goes to show you that
sometimes disasters can turn out armed
awesome I'll see you on Friday and by
Friday I mean right now because you're
holding the camera